joining me now is newt gingrich former
speaker of the house and fox news
contributor
uh newt the left is so desperate at this
point to save themselves from utter
annihilation in november
they've decided to become
the flag wavers and to claim
treason on the part of anyone who has or
dares to question them your reaction
tonight
well part of that isn't a big change
they've always been prepared to smother
anybody who disagrees with them to kick
them out to cancel them to fire them to
drive them out of public life so that
they've changed a little bit of the
direction but the attitude hasn't
changed look the problem for the left is
simple it's failing
it's failing in ukraine
it's failing with inflation
it's failing with open borders
it's failing with levels of crime
when you go through area after area i
just talked today to a pollster about
new york state which is a state which
bow by which biden carried by a huge
margin he's now some 25 points under
water in a state he carried by a big
margin because people wake up in the
morning and they look here the most
recent examples the guy who stabbed two
people staff people at the museum of
modern art the person is going around as
a serial killer killing people who are
homeless
people look at that stuff and they say
this isn't working then they go to buy
gasoline that's not working uh wait till
you see the impact of the price of wheat
which is actually going up faster than
the price of oil uh presently you're
going to see food problems that are
amazing and people are going to say this
isn't working
and i think when you watch biden and and
you watch harris the question is which
is the more incompetent
i mean harris in poland was an utter
total embarrassment
and every american had to feel something
was wrong there
and of course biden i think is totally
out of touch with reality and this been
pathetic the result by the way is the
chinese are now more important you have
syrians potentially coming into europe
as a fighting force you have europeans
who have no respect for the current
american administration
and you have putin thinking as long as
he yells nuclear war he can get away
with anything he wants to including
killing civilians bombing maternity
hospitals attacking nuclear reactors
and you have an administration in
washington which is just totally i think
out of touch with reality
back to your point on the crime in the
united states because i think what we're
seeing in these polls newt as
as
as awful and tragic and horrific as
putin's war on ukraine is
the mom and pop small businesses the
american families are most concerned
about what's happening in their schools
and what's happening to their family
budgets and what's happening on the
streets it's so bad in seattle that we
learned tonight that amazon is at least
temporarily relocating 1100 or 1800 of
its employees
out of seattle because it's become such
a hell hole of crime
i think this is an opportunity do you
not agree for a republican 50 state
strategy to wipe the democrats out in
2024 2022 not just in the old red state
blocks but across the country from new
york to washington state to california
and beyond
well look i think republicans should
encourage candidates everywhere i will
say the congressional campaign committee
has done an amazing job i think they're
going to have more candidates than we
had in 1994 which at the time set a
record uh when you look for example at
san francisco where the school board
members who were who were recalled with
an over 70 vote that was led by asian
americans who are deeply offended that
these left-wing nutcakes want to destroy
the schools which asian-americans see as
the key to their children's future when
you look at for example uh hispanic
americans they're patriotic they are
pro-life they are for the work ethic
they believe in take-home pay they are
anti-crime and they look at a democratic
party which increasingly looks crazy i
mean you had 89 democrats today sign a
letter to biden from the house saying
that the greatest threat is global
warming now we're in the middle of a war
and the greatest threat is global
warming i mean how whacked out do you
have to be
new it's great to see you as always
tonight thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else